Android patterns for performance
At any time when you can drive less accurate results,
Will achieve a significant gain in performance.
I'm Joanna Smith.
I will show you how to balance the need for perfect performance
And maintain complete satisfaction to your users.
The rounding revolves around saving voltage
And make things good enough for users
Then convince the developers that it is OK to do this.
Consider implementing a trip plan that uses the user's location
Remember to fill the car with gasoline or suggest restaurants to eat in
Or great landmarks to visit.
This application does not need the exact location of the device
To perform these functions.
A zip code may be all it needs
Until the user accepts a suggestion
Then ask for navigation directions.
GPS accuracy should be increased.
This is the practical application of approximation.
Which minimizes user time and displays a less accurate result
But they meet the current need of the user.
How much time your app is wasting to provide a more accurate result
At a time when the user does not notice the least accurate result?
We can find savings because of the approximation of everything.
Such as the flight plan application we presented.
While driving the user on that very long road,
There is no need to bring updates from the server every five minutes exactly.
Your app can instead configure payments and schedule requests
Accuracy and repeat less to keep the battery
Which the user will need if the window is punctured.
The app can also calculate a route between two cities in the trip
Then use the estimated travel time to set the alarm clock later in the future
The GPS is activated and turned on
So that suggestions can be presented again.
But until there is a nearby area of ​​interest that deserves to be offered to the user,
There is little point in tracking a user's site
Along this long and empty highway.
Of course, there are simple approximations
Such as allowing slightly less precision for your images
To save memory space
And increased display speed.
This is because when the user browses
A list of potential stops along the way,
Does not need full picture details yet.
You can even load it when you inspect the decor of the restaurant you choose.
I will repeat what I said earlier so please listen.
For the vast majority of code,
No 100% accurate results are needed.
And by combining the demand for a few devices
Giving users everything they need,
Can gain a lot of frame rate
And provide battery life.
So the roundabout is essentially about compromise.
This is no different from everything else in performance.
So you'll lose the rest of your Android Performance Patterns
Think about joining the G + forum for tips, guidance, and help.
So keep calm, collect your code information
Always remember that performance is important.